hello everybody and welcome to my third
Advanced flipping guide today I'm going
to be showing you how I flip rare items
uh so it's going to be costly to start
off you'll need a lot of money to start
with uh but the payoff can be
extraordinarily High uh I'm going to go
over what sort of items are considered
rare um how to find items that will be
good to flip um that are rare as well
cuz not all of them actually are very
good at for flipping uh how to find the
margin of the items because it can very
costly to check it if you're not doing
it right um we're going to do some
example flips I show you some footage of
uh flips I've done in the past or some
I've done pretty recently and lastly
we're going to go over a list of items
uh that tend to work well now of course
these are just for ideas you don't want
to necessarily rely just on this list uh
because it's publicly available uh but
it'll give you some ideas on where to
start when you're flipping rare items
all right let's get started okay so to
start off uh what would be considered a
rare idea item and I Define a rare item
generally by the trade volume so the
amount that are traded per day is kind
of how I defined how rare an item is uh
so when I can when I'm considering
something to be rare I would say it has
no greater than 500 traded a day and
that would be pushing it a little bit
for me I wouldn't go above 500 because
the item then is the margin tends to be
much smaller uh people are trade them
all the time you don't have as much
opportunity to snag a rare item for
cheaper when some guy gets it saf from a
clue scroll reward or just gets an
imbued heart randomly or something that
someone doesn't need but someone else
might um you won't have as big an
opportunity to snag it for low and then
sell it to someone who needs it uh I
would try to keep the volume under 500
under 200 would be ideal uh to have the
largest margin but at the same time it
still has to be an item that's traded so
i' try to keep at least 20 or 30 traded
a day any below that and then it's risky
the item can fluctuate down when someone
needs it you could be holding on to the
item for days and not even make a
successful flip uh so to start we'll
show you some items and how I find the
trade volume uh so I'm using G tracker
uh link will be in the description it's
just a website to check up on the
analytics of items in the grand exchange
uh so what we're going to do is look at
some items uh first of all let's look at
an item I won't do but would be kind of
considered rare so like the Abyssal whip
let's open that
up uh so the Abyssal whip it's an
expensive item it's a rare item to get
like it's not a very common drop but
it's a very commonly used item um the
trade volume per day is up 3,000 4,000
uh you're not ever going to get a very
good margin on this although the item
has been raising up but we're trying to
ignore Trends here and just focus on
what we can get um per day and you can
see here the the price doesn't really
fluctuate a whole lot it's just trending
upwards but that's going to take way too
long um now let's look at an item uh say
from a clue scroll reward uh so one I've
been doing recently is the dragon citar
ornament kit uh now this trade volume is
much lower I believe it's 30 or 40
what's a little bit higher than that so
there's a 50 to 60 traded a day uh which
is pretty nice for what we're looking
for here um and we're going to go down
to the day graph okay so it doesn't look
like a big difference here uh but when
we're talking this is like a 10 20%
increase that adds up to a lot of money
as so we can see here someone sold it
for
4510 um s someone bought it for 4510 and
uh later someone sold it for
4660 that is a oh is that me no wait I'm
over here um but you can see that is a
150 200k margin on item like this and uh
I mean look tons tra enough traded I
wouldn't say tons but even if you
flipped five or six of these that could
leave to a mil or a Mill and a half in
profit okay so this is a little bit of
an extreme example but the third age
pickaxe so you would imagine this item
would have a huge margin on it here and
look 125 mil so I mean it sounds great
of course it's an insanely expensive
item um but if you look at the dayby day
for how much is traded there is like one
traded a week uh this is an extreme hug
example even for items only have three
or four traded a day uh the item pricing
fluctuates so much and you would think
that's a good thing but uh really it
just leads to a highly volatile item you
could lose out big on this item because
someone might not necessarily buy it for
that price or sell it for that price it
could go either way you're just as
likely to make 100 Mil as you are to
lose 100 Mil uh unless you're going to
be extremely patient but this is a
little too extreme uh even for me um but
those are three examples of the items
the second example is what you're
looking for a item that has a medium
amount of quantity at traded per day in
the range of 30 to 200 okay so now I'm
going to go over how I check for an
items margin uh because rare items do
have large margins uh you can stand to
lose quite a bit by checking them uh but
here are the two ways you do it so you
either do it normally you buy one and
sell one instantly uh which works for
certain rare items and but I wouldn't
recommend doing it for all of them or
you do use a GE tracker or another grand
exchange tracking Tool uh to have a at
the price when I would normally check an
item is maybe when the buying quantity
is around 200 300 upwards uh because at
that point the trade volume is enough
that the uh delay on the tracking tools
uh make it so the information is usually
invalid or not very accurate in the
ballpark maybe but not exact by any
means um so let's have a look at an item
quickly uh so I brought the armadel page
three uh now on G tracker it says we
have 135k margin
um but since the uh the buying limit is
10000 I wouldn't say that item or that
price is very accurate so we're going to
go ahead and check it right now so it's
saying that the um we'll go down and
check exactly what it's
referring oh that's actually a little
higher but um anyway it's saying the
last sell price was 504 the last Buy
price was 509 oh that really sucks but
anyway we bought it for 1
mil and uh we're going to sell it for
9k so that is a crazy large margin on
the book um page unfortunately probably
not going to get that uh so that being
said this was very inaccurate you can
see that there would I flip this item
right now probably not the reason why uh
the price I bought it at
509 uh is quite a bit higher than the
item is regularly at all the time so you
very easily lose money unless I made a
quick flip on this I would say it's a
noo um now for an item like the dragon
Scimitar ornament kit uh which we looked
at earlier the trade limit on this item
or not the trade limit the trade
quantity is only about 30 or 40 um and
we can go down to the day graph and
since there's only a couple traded every
hour we can get a pretty accurate um
view on how expensive the item is so if
we have a look here this is me I no not
where is
[Music]
it I well anyway I put my offer in for
four uh
460 and somewhere in here but anyway I
realized um someone had undercut me
right here so 4460 and one and then I
moved my Buy price up by a little bit to
4462 and those are my prices though I
they're very accurate because the volume
is very low so it gives it time for the
uh website to update the information so
for items that have a trade limit of
under 50 or maybe even 100 depending on
the item I would recommend uh just
looking at the information and then
popping in a relevant Buy offer okay
guys so now I'm going to show you an
example flip now this is going to be one
where I just check the margin regularly
I flip the item like any other item it's
just a rare item uh a lot more money to
do so but it can easily be worth the uh
investment to check the margin uh so now
we're going to start off with the Bandos
God Sword I would even consider this a
rare item but I'm going to show you the
distinction between this and the magic
Fang which I'm going to do a minute in a
minute uh so this item only has a 30k
margin and the reason mainly behind this
is there's thous a thousand of these
traded a day and uh it's not really a
rare item it's just an expensive item
that is traded actually quite a
reasonable amount so we're only going to
get a 30k margin here that being said
it's still a pretty good item to flip we
can we're going to do five of these and
uh we can get that done probably an hour
uh but but you can really tell the
difference between an item like this and
the magic Fang which only has 200 or 300
traded a day um the margin really does
get reflected in that amount all right
so now on to the magic Fang uh we'll see
if we can buy it instantly no we can't
so again this item trades 200 to 300 a
day uh Dro from zra if you didn't know
uh we'll instantly buy it for
2588 and uh we'll sell it for
2475 so this has a 100K margin on it uh
which is three times the amount of the
Bandos God Sword even though it's a
cheaper item and this will still flip
reasonably quickly uh but the difference
in the quantity really makes a
difference in the margin um the band's
God Zord would be good if you were going
to be here the whole time but the magic
Fang is the perfect item if you're going
to go away for a couple hours or leave
it in overnight all right guys so we'll
leave these items for a little bit and
we'll come back when they both have sold
okay so we are back and we've sold both
the items uh now the Bandos godsword uh
because it changes prices a lot uh we
sold the back exactly what we bought it
for so it really didn't work too well uh
the magic Fang however uh we can got the
109k margin that we wanted uh we sold
five of them so we got 545k in profit
from this item which is really good um
that being said we do have to take 109k
off for checking the margin still
436k uh from investing 10 mil only so
about a 4% return uh really not too bad
so now I'm going to go over an example
flip where I have just check the margin
on uh ge tracker or another grand
exchange uh tracking website so to start
off I found an item here which I think
might be good and this is the dragon
Defender ornament kit uh the trade limit
or the quantity sorry is uh between 25
and 50 so I think I could get an
accurate uh price for the buy and sell
offers so now um we have this under the
month by the way to check so this will
bring it break it down to per day uh
which is just kind of easy to visualize
um how many per day it's traded now once
we've established that there's a a
reasonable quantity uh per day we're
going to come up here to the price and
uh now this is interesting we can go
down all the way to the day and this is
what I really like about uh this graph
here is you can see the difference
between the buy and sell prices right in
the graph form uh so we can see the last
uh recorded Buy price was 3340 and the
last recorded sell price is 30840 so
that is a
300K profit uh which could be quite nice
and they trade uh quite a bit every hour
uh so we're going to go ahead and do
this item we'll plop an offering for
roughly
3340 and um this is the dragon Defender
ornament
kit 30 3
[Music]
41k and just to bite this now I know I'm
undercutting and honestly a lot of the
times when I do this I probably
shouldn't but for items like this where
there's only 10 or 20 traded a day there
is not room for multiple people doing
this item
so undercutting is not okay but it kind
of just has to be done uh because if you
put it in for the same price you'll be
both be waiting hours in hours maybe
even days to buy your items um it's kind
of just up to you to find an item that
nobody else has done but I might be
wrong I'm totally up for a discussion
regarding this but anyway 3341 is what
we're going to put it in for and uh well
we'll just do two fortunately we can't
quite afford
three 3341 and uh we'll come back when
the item has sold okay so we only
managed to get one uh we waited uh only
about an hour and a half or something
and we bought the one
and then we kind of got impatient and
decided to sell it uh but that being
said we sold it for 3840 which was right
on the nose the last recorded sell price
uh so we'll claim that and uh right
there let's have a look
[Music]
here that is 500k in profit we made just
off this item really didn't take very
long just requires a little bit of uh
pre-planning and looking at some
information so now I'm going to quickly
go go over what probably a lot of you
guys are waiting for and what items uh
work well and what are some example
items uh so now I've broken it down to
three main categories that have a lot of
rare items in them and the first in main
category is going to be clue scroll
rewards this makes up a large majority
of the items that I flip uh some good
options here ornament kits gilded items
pages but honestly if you just open up
uh the master clue reward the hard clue
reward
and just look at the items there's a
huge list of them there for you to
observe and look at a lot of those work
pretty well again just look at uh the
items quantity and everything else that
I showed you this video and uh a lot of
good items there boss drops work pretty
well uh items like the interal Crystal
paging Crystal uh if you have a lot of
money you can do Hilt drops from God
Wars um Abyssal bludgeon stuff I
wouldn't do the Abyssal whip so much um
but Abyssal bludgeon Abyssal dagger
also the Slayer drops tend to have some
rare items not as much items like uh the
dragon chain body or like the imbued
heart are pretty rare uh the reason why
there aren't as many items in the Slayer
category is people do Slayer a lot um
tons of the rare items a lot of them end
up in the game like the Abyssal whip
dark Bow a lot of them end up in the
game cuz people are grinding out Slayer
they get a lot of kills a lot more items
end up in the game uh so those are three
categories uh a lot of good items in
there and that's where I would start
when I'm looking for items that are rare
to flip all right guys that about wraps
it up I hope you guys enjoyed my uh
Advanced flipping guide number three for
rare items um I'd love to hear what
items you guys have had success doing of
course you don't have to post it if
you're currently flipping it um but if
you have some uh items that you've done
I would love if you left a comment down
below uh for some items and just to get
motivation for people who have never
really tried flipping rare items before
cuz there's a lot of money to be had and
a lot of items to do all right guys I
hope you enjoyed the video and I'll see
you guys next time